the Jeremy Corbyn isn't a statistic a
genuine passwords which I admit is very
hard to be is against all wars
everywhere
Corbin John McDonnell all the people
they've bought into the Labor Party have
made endless excuses for Russian
imperialism for Islamic terrorism and
for role bizarrely at the same time
Assad this is not behaviour pacifist
this is behavior of very slippery
characters who are don't quite have the
guts to say openly support Russian
armies are losing to Ukraine but do
everything else to justifies
if you look at Corbin's response most of
this true character comes out that again
there's his slipperiness there's this
our inability to just speak plainly what
he believes he does believe that all
violence or misery or terrorism in the
world is ultimately the root cause of it
is ultimately the West therefore you
know it makes perfect sense for him to
go along stop the war so what happens in
Paris is just blowback and we shouldn't
be surprised by it all or even that
concern by it but then then he keeps
dodging and weaving and hiding and
saying well I didn't quite mean that
when I said the police shouldn't shoot
someone who's murdering people on the
street I'll go back on that or I'm not
really against the ground strike on
jihadi john' I just think that um he
should have been arrested and taken to
court well how is he going to be
arrested the only conceivable way to
arrest him is to have special forces
because very forces go into Syria and
kidnapping which of course Jeremy Corbyn
woods would have opposed so it's yeah
everyone goes on about him being
authentic and free from spin actually
he's one of the most inauthentic and and
dangerous politicians you're like to
come across and that's saying something
well I don't think he could ever been
legal I don't think they had this absurd
electoral system where people who aren't
lega party members who have never voted
the labor should vote but it will depend
it will depend on numbers at the moment
his supporters can say with justice tens
of thousands of people voted for him
labor for Labour MPs do anything labour
is going to have to start losing
elections and by-elections which power
leads me a very paradoxical position if
you want to get rid of the Tory
government if you want to have a Labour
opposition that has a chance of winning
in general election the last thing you
should do at the moment is vote Labour